I think way too many people when they
think there are managers think people
are working for them and I think when
people are mentors they think that
they're working for the other person and
I think all the best managers are
actually Mentors
[Music]
we stopped
[Music]
[Music]
they say is ever that your confidence
that way your accomplishments and never
that' compliments kill your view of
incompetence a lot can happen in a year
to the top watch your pet return a
legend I'm still got in my proud reason
I give away all my content is the magic
is in the last mile right it's the last
it's the details and the unique
situation of a business or an
entrepreneur that actually matters right
like I can get people to third and a
half base third and three fourths base
but I can change people's business to
them in front of them if they just give
me all the details and it goes from
being philosophical to practical and so
the way it differs when I'm actually
consulting for mentoring or some part of
a board or a marketing board or an
investor and I want the outcome to work
is I'm actually looking at every detail
of the situation and I'm bringing value
within context not just the errata
naive indifferent at the start I guess
they knew we'd be fine
I guess the warm-up ducks impressed him
he was jumping from that started shul
from drink not a yes is he sad not mine
early disease you know and you know like
so what we need to do is the word that
they strike where I think the
opportunist which is why strategy la
alligator that tests my status its
bossing the time to rest now I'm rolling
quite like if she clearly yellow the
best
anything can attention anything saying
like you so noise to learn everything
matters information matters but not the
cliche thing that everybody does all the
time
really great had a huge crime pitch
looking to get some people Heine sorta
kinda sorta behind a sort of had a
client pick just I miss one um what
really well big one to me
uh talk about being a social here that
it's serious about that um I work at
some honest cop down there I also ate
way too much guacamole last night I so
much for malaria how was that last night
great right that was like that's like
good [ __ ] right
last night somebody I can see in the
blog was I had what do we have about
fifteen of us here fifteen just
different groups of people that work at
Bainer you met a bunch of new people
show other people do rock show a night
what was that again that's exactly right
when you're running a big when you're
running a big organization got it for
seven dippity sometimes so that was good
things of then Nicholson's here is there
trouble just assisting politics any time
I got my head off well exact I'm not
concerned where your science don't try
it people looking down and talk and
disbelieve that's cool but my family's
looking down and they don't push me
through my pops escape the genocide I'm
lucky I'm here 1940 back and hungry had
no comfort of their my pops escape the
genocide in Lhasa all right
tomorrow 9:30 a.m. how to start the best
film we've ever made and really the film
that most people on YouTube and the
internet world people watch so many
people here that shouldn't be producing
video because that is not the best way
they communicate only a decade ago if I
was speaking here all I would be talking
about is blogging highlight why did you
run this office is gonna be so proper
next summer even this summer I don't I
don't I don't have so much as I am
service
[Music]
ask him ask him ask my common senses is
factored into the equation in marketing
today I'm being that's here that's
actually my question when they when they
feel like they've got something to say
I've got experience and have the
emotions around actually giving back I
don't think there's an official line I
think anybody who's a good manager has
mental shift DNA within I think way too
many people when they think there are
managers think people working for them
and I think when people are mentors they
think that they're working for the other
person and I think all the best managers
are actually mentors I've always
actually think about it all the time
because I'm always think about how do I
provide more value as a businessman as
an owner and a leader and a personality
with my audience my natural glue fault
is to be a head coach a mentor a big
brother a leader I think the reason I'm
such a fan of mentorship is it equates
to actual legacy legacy comes in the
form of what people say about you when
you're not around and being a great
mentor and advisor leads to those
they want to hear me talk to me cause
money in fashion I owe the world my
gratitude but things I imagine asking
questions I should accomplish things
that I could if it weren't for the doubt
with people thinking I wouldn't pass to
deep emotions to real to feel the words
and so I'm still hard on well for new
speeds and merge everything I want is
everything that I became the class clown
searching yourself a typical thing we're
going to go around
hopefully you have two or three ideas on
good videos good video ideas adjustment
iris can create those 14 videos we're
going to build and create and support
through I see stories through designs
through graphics through distribution
through planning and project management
dalvio is going to help with specific
tactical videos okay YouTube subscribe
download my podcasts and other like
Danny has a great idea about a specific
Instagram video these two are busy da VL
is going to step in and make especially
on like Facebook not just like the same
title square type thing so more vertical
stuff different things like that
Instagram
regular means in place I'm just
switching it up yeah it's the same
reason why I say like we really need a
thing about the headlines the titles
graphics you know thumbs toppers the
mobile phone once we like feed you guys
content you can visualize like hmm this
is probably a good vertical one like
this is a good one to try and break
something and do like or like you know
what I mean taking whatever content
you're trying to create and be like I
think this would be a good format for it
yeah come on Chris
we got a little flutter on two big
things last year is actually and it was
Gary's idea and I again bitter about it
it was his idea but it was one of the
best things that our team did he said he
wanted up a competition like that Gainey
break the team up into like teams of
three and the job is you guys have you
created a video and the team that
creates the best video wins and what
happened like we created five amazing
videos and they're some of the best
videos we had made but nothing else had
really changed it was just like all of a
sudden we had that mentality it's like
oh let's [ __ ] make an awesome video
sometimes like when we add on these
people and I'm like trying to have other
people manage everything we lose them
and touting just like all this is what
LA wants let's give it that lead but you
don't necessarily believe in it like
it's a balance of trying to destroy that
and just create the best things like you
want it less cooled you very rarely
would Elliot be like hey let's try the
same style and maybe like no definitely
not we're sticking to this format you
know
um yeah another than that I just take
this energy and keep making good things
I'm thinking of like I think my idea of
using music Jake creating the music and
I think everyone else has another
similar idea that we can start doing
[Music]
[Music]
rock where you do I wore daily I would
like a daily view when you take it right
a daily V daily view and Gary's ever
talks it's everyone else talking and
just shows him listening and it's about
how because all you ever hear is how
loud he is how much he interrupts Now
Big E is but he really does listen so
like yeah meaning when I'm talking to
Gary and I say D rock sucks we don't
love it cool yeah
we have a big team or three designers
video people and a whole lot of other
characters seth join us in two weeks
banner social will be a cool way for us
to expand our capabilities
oh well my credit to for things like
imagine asking questions I should
things that I could if it weren't for
the doubt and people thinking I wouldn't
pass to deep emotions to real to feel to
words so I still know harder
well-produced beats and merge everything
I want is everything that I became the
class clown turn genius now headed for
fame
[Music]